et on poursuit cette page loisir Gabriel
avec vos idées de sortie pour les
vacances de la toussin et on commence
avec un match qui devrait intéresser les
amateurs de foot ce weekend on vous en
parlait hier oui on commence avec un
rendez-vous sportif Mathilde le FC
Versailles jouera à domisile au stade
montboron ce samedi 28 octobre à 14h30
les ivelinois affronteront le FC Fleury
91 pour un match de Coupe de France une
bonne nouvelle pour les supporters qui
depuis la saison dernière n'avait
assisté à aucun match national sur le
stade versaillais en raison on l'a dit
hier Mathilde des travaux d'éclairage
des places sont encore disponible pour
assister à la rencontre sur le site
internet du club toujours en sport
Gabriel vous nous parlez d'une
exposition à montiny le Bretonneux
histoire sport et citoyenneté voici la
thématique de l'exposition qui retrace
l'histoire du sport depuis les Jeux
Olympiques d'Athène en
1896 aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 trois lieux
sont dédiés à l'exposition selon les
périodes présentées dans les maisons de
quartiers Henry Matis André merau et
Louis Jouvet l'entrée est libre et
l'exposition se tient jusqu'au 10
novembre une bonne manière de préparer
les jeux dont une partie de l'histoire
s'écrira en 2024 sur le sol iblinois
alors direction toiri à présent même si
la ville n'accueille pas les gios elle
accueille un événement presque aussi
grandiose presque aussi grandiose je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas les lumières
sauvages reviennent à toari dès le 29
octobre pour la la 6e année consécutive
cette année encore les jardins se
métamorphosent pour vous offrir un
spectacle féérique nouveauté cette année
le labyrinthe sera illuminé vous pourrez
également découvrir les 2700
illuminations au travers un parcours
inédit de 2 km cette année c'est l'Asie
qui est mise à l'honneur vous y
trouverez donc temple Bouddha géant ou
encore une représentation de la jungle
asiatique et pourquoi ne pas profiter
des vacances pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir l'espace rambouillé oui
cette année pour la première fois le
parc accueille les visiteurs dans une
atmosphère magique et envoûante où les
conttes et les légendes des esprits de
la forêt prenne vie au programme
spectacle et animation Brigitte
teinturier responsable marketing de
l'espace rambouillé nous parle du lieu
et des animations voici l'interview
Express réalisée par Julien
[Musique]
Leroi l'espace rouille c'est un parc
forestier animalier qui est dédié à à
tout ce qui est présenter l'écosystème
forestier ses animaux pour sensibiliser
le plus grand nombre à la biodiversité
et sa
préservation depuis qu'on a ouvert au
mois d'avril on a un petit train
électrique qui permet en fait aux jeunes
enfants et aux personnes qui ont des
difficultés pour se déplacer de
découvrir la forêt sauvage on
a la partie la forêt des milécureuil où
là on va avoir la présentation sur des
trampolines géants qui sont installés
entre les
[Musique]
arbres on met en place un événement avec
des spectacles et des animations donc du
spectacle vivant avec de la pyrotechnie
on est vraiment sur une thématique qui
allie la magie le côté onyrique et
féérique on va avoir un celt qui arbore
des bois de serr qui va rencontrer une
Dade donc une une une nymphe des des
bois de la forêt on va avoir des
cavaliers de
[Musique]
lumière et à quelques jours d'Halloween
on termine Gabriel avec un rendez-vous
qui va nous mettre dans l'ambiance oui
encore un peu de patience Mathilde avant
le grand soir d'Halloween mais des
animations ont lieu dès maintenant
demain soir à Guy en cour une marche
nocturne est organisée au programme
déambulation animation bal folk et
dégustation de la soupe des sorcières
les bénéfices de la soirée seront
intégralement reversés au Téléton à
noter également que les 30 et 31
octobrees des ateliers de décoration et
des ateliers culinaires sont organisés
pour bien préparer votre fête et bien
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces idées de sortie